this Austrian feature from 2014 is a
master class in making the audience feel
very very bad two twins develop a
syndrome that makes them believe their
mother lost in depression after being
disfigured in an accident has been
replaced by an impostor the story
unfolds with train wreck inevitability
as their investigation turns from
Curious to cruel playing with the
allegiances of the audience in an
excruciating way the story is riddled
with blank spaces and patches of Silence
where a lesser film would try to tell
the audience too much the amazing result
is that the viewers have to do the leg
work on figuring out what's really going
on and the film is not so much about
jump surprises as it is about the pure
horror of watching innocent children do
terrible unspeakable things